hey hey do you my name is Samuel Leeds
and I'm a property investor and in this
video I wanted to give you my 5 top tips
for being a profitable buy-to-let
property investor so tip number one is
when you're buying the property and
you're buying it to hold on to it and
rent it out I would always say try and
find ways you can add value to the
property so for example if the outside
looks a bit shabby it might only cost
five hundred pounds to paint the outside
but it might add two thousand pounds
worth of value to the house so for every
one pound that you spend you want to be
getting three pounds back or lifting the
property three pounds in value so that's
tip number one how can you add value to
your bite slip property tip number two
is to run a successful profitable
buy-to-let property company is to find
the tenant yourself I know I'm a very
systemized kind of person I speak a lot
about systemization in my other YouTube
videos letting agents often charge a lot
of money to find a tenant to met the
tenant to move the tenant in you can be
talking hundreds and hundreds sometimes
even thousands of pounds depending on
the property so what I would recommend a
little tip trick for you guys is go to a
website called open rent docked Cote UK
and you can list properties yourself on
open rent very inexpensively now when
you do that the property will be then
featured on Rightmove Cody UK through
open rent which is going to give it
masses a massive exposure not only that
but when you have a letting agent
advertising your property they're
getting inundated every day from all
kinds of requests from tenants trying to
view properties whereas you if you get
called about this property that you put
on you only have one house so every
tenant that calls you you're going to be
trying to sell this house to them so I
think advertising your house yourself
through open rent credit UK it's
certainly gonna mean that you're gonna
save money from paying a letting agent
but it's also going to mean that you can
probably get a tenant in better and
faster and you can do all the references
all the checks as an agent would do you
can do that through open rent code okay
tip number three is find a good tenant
for goodness sake the only thing that's
worse than no tenant is a bad tenant you
not one bad tenant so again if you're
using open rent and you can vet the
tenants yourself and only on the
references and the credit checks but you
can also physically meet them at the
property and you can see you know do I
like this person does this person seem
to be a good reasonable clean human
being that I would want living in my
property or do they seem like they're on
the run and they're shabby and they've
got 21 cats and three dogs not there's
anything wrong with cats and dogs but
you'll get a real sense rather than just
looking at a piece of paper do you like
lieutenant can I tell you something you
want to make sure that you've got a good
tenant in your house my property is that
on paper are now doing the best that are
given me the best return on investment
there it's always the case they've got
the best tenants they've had the same
tenants in for many many years so find a
good tenants tip number four is give
gifts give gifts what I mean by that the
agent who found you the house give them
a bottle of wine your tenants that are
paying you your rent give them Christmas
gifts send them cards because a gift
work might only cost you 10 or 20 pounds
but believe me when you're in the
property investment game a gift will go
a long way buying a 20 pound bottle of
wine for an estate agent that found you
a good house might mean that they phone
you next week
with a property which has got a 20,000
pound discount on it just because you
were thinking of them and they like you
buying your tenant a Christmas card or
some chocolates and saying thank you for
being a great tenant could be the
difference between them staying in your
property for ten years or two years it
could be the difference between when
they leave then leaving the property a
bit messy and untidy or doing viewings
for you making your life really easy for
20 pounds so it's one of the best
investments you can make in property is
giving gifts to people that have helped
you in your journey as a property
investor number five when you've added
value to your property and you've found
your own kenneth's and you've moved them
in and they're good tenants and
everything's going well always try and
refinance the house I think don't leave
equity setting properties most people
say I'm going to pay the mortgage off as
fast as possible that is actually not
very smart because debt shrinks over
time your best to avoid paying off the
mortgage
let the debt shrink over time because
money shrinks in value as inflation goes
up and then refinance as often as you
can and then use that equity to buy more
properties you've got leverage to make a
lot more money
those are my five top tips to how you
can be a profitable property investor in
the UK by tulip market if you enjoyed
that please do subscribe don't forget to
smash that like button and leave your
comments below and I'll try and answer
as many as I possibly can
thanks so much
[Music]